in chess
we always talk about in-game i do the
same thing in juditsu
i start experts just looking at the
mechanics
of breaking people and all the
sufficient holds that i teach you should
know that i teach only
a very small number of submission holds
around six
um it's interesting my students have by
far and away the highest submission rate
in contemporary jujitsu but they only
learn around six to seven submission
holds
i start them with mechanics where they
learn the end game
how to break someone
once they develop in their mind
the belief that if the conditional if
they can get to one of those six
positions
there's a very high likelihood they'll
win
if they truly believe then
when it's competition time they'll
[ __ ] find a way
to get to those positions that's
confidence but if you don't believe
let's say you believe
man if i get to a finishing position an
armbar or a strangle
there's only like a 20 chance i'll
finish with it how hard are you going to
fight to get to that position
you're not why why would you
but if you believe there's a 98 chance
if you get to that position you'll
finish you'll find a way to get down
that is so powerful there are certain
things that may be going back to judo a
little bit as
the there's a clock choke for people who
are
listening it's with the ghee when a
purple
or when a person is in a turtle position
in a crouching position
this is something that's done in judo
quite a bit but i have doesn't matter
what the technique is
i have a belief in my head that there's
not a person in the world
that i can't choke with that clock choke
leaf and i've done that and that
it was um it built on itself
the belief made the technique better and
better and better
now you're on to something that's
exactly the mindset that i'm trying to
coach
but that's step one you have to believe
that
but you've got to stop somewhere and
then it's step one but then you have to
create a system but it's a damn
important step
yeah so you coach the end game first and
then you fill in the details afterwards
yeah that's a huge confidence builder
but i just i have to say
to admit and it makes me sad but i think
i'm not alone i think i'm a majority of
jiu jitsu people are like this
that uh i didn't do the the beginner
step that you talk about which is the
focusing and escapes i think i learned
the wrong lessons
from being from losing i remember
in a blue belt competition long ago one
i was uh i think it was yeah it was the
finals of atlanta ibjf tournament
and there's a person that passed my
guard
and he took him out and
he stayed in mount for a long time
and i couldn't breathe and it was like
one of those things where i was
truly dominated i don't think i've been
dominated
you just matched quite like that before
and or after
and the lesson i learned from that is
i'm not going to let
like as opposed to working on escapes
i'm not going to let anyone pass my
guard what you learned is don't take
risks
don't take risks which is
ultimately what kills you ultimately you
become the best you can
you got to take risks as they say
nothing risk nothing gained
failure usually makes us even more
risk-averse than we started we're
already
mentally biased being human beings in
that direction and failure tends to
reinforce that um
i work hard in my training programs to
try and correct that fold
you